espan 98 for pricing information and to
request a tape
now book tv looks at plato's republic
first part one of an interview with
author and boston university philosophy
professor stanley rosen then will watch
a book group discussion of the republic
we'll return to part two of professor
rosen's interview where he comments on
the group discussion and expands on
greek life and plato's works this
complete program lasts two hours and
twenty minutes
professor stan rosen of boston
university who was plato
plato was the student of socrates
more precisely he's usually regarded as
the founder
of the history of philosophy in its more
formal sense
in other words there were a number of
figures
called wise men or even
philosophers who lived before plato but
he's the first person to have created a
substantial body of work of
philosophical work
and is uh regarded as the kind of
fountainhead of the western
philosophical tradition when did he live
well he lived
in the fifth and fourth centuries bc he
was born in 428 and died in something
like 348.
so he in other words encompassed the
the peloponnesian war and the loss of
the athenian empire the glory and the
decay of classical greece you could say
plato's life spanned that period i
should go back and ask you based on your
first answer who was socrates socrates
was plato's teacher
socrates was a very extraordinary man
who never wrote anything
he was famous for
asking people embarrassing questions
such as what is truth or what is the
good life
or why did you do
what you did when you took your father
to court for impiety or something of
that sort socrates uh in other words
trained
uh a group of people whom the most
famous was plato he did that largely or
almost entirely as far as we know orally
simply by conversation with them hence
the famous socratic method
of asking questions and
carrying on philosophy in the dialogue
form rather than delivering formal
lectures
what would they have been like back in
athens uh in in what 2500 years ago what
would have
how important would they have been in
that community people like socrates and
plato yes well you know that's an
extremely interesting question socrates
we we revere socrates today as a great
philosopher and the as plato said the
justice man of his day
socrates reputation was not that good in
athens he was associated
uh with troublemakers because he went
around asking embarrassing questions
like what is the nature of the divine
do the gods actually do and say the
things that our great poet theologians
like homer and hesiod have said that
they say in other words socrates was
perceived by the average athenian as a
kind of eccentric
who represented a danger to the
stability of the state
and many of the people with whom
socrates spoke
were sons young sons of the wealthiest
and politically most prominent families
and by engaging these young kids in
conversation about such fundamental
questions as what is justice socrates
was implicitly committing treason
because obviously the official answer to
the question what is justice is whatever
the athenian laws say it is so socrates
was considered a rather difficult person
and finally
through a series of circumstances that
it would take too long to summarize at
the moment was put to death by the city
plato was in a slightly different
position he was very rich
belonged to a very prominent family
had a great political career ahead of
him which he
entered into briefly
at a quite a young age and then dropped
out of
and devoted the rest of his life uh to
philosophical research he also founded
the first uh as we would call it to the
university plato's academy so he he was
a man who uh who had the opportunity to
go into politics
and who uh tried it and
turned it down and devoted himself to
teaching and writing his famous
dialogues and training his students who
carried on the tradition
uh at plato's academy or we would say
university in a few minutes we're going
to show a discussion
about 12 people sitting around a table
at politics and pro's bookstore here in
northwest washington and it's called the
classics book group and they do this
every
first tuesday of each month
and it's if we've had it on tape since
the jen and july
it's interesting to watch just the
average person i don't know that they
want to be called the average person
sitting around talking about plato and
socrates and all of this that you're
talking about how long have you taught
this subject
approximately 43 years
43 years now how are the kids in the
over the years in your classes there
because they choose to be or is it
is it a requirement at either penn state
where you were for 38 years or at boston
university where you've been for five
well of course my classes are of two
kinds undergraduate and graduate the
graduate courses are those in which i
train
people who wish to become professors of
philosophy or professional philosophers
in some way the attendance there is all
voluntary
the undergraduate courses are mixed
one course i teach is an undergraduate
introductory course with 185 students
and it's hard to give you a general
statement uh but most of them are there
because they want to be
in other words it's true that they'll
have to take an elective course in
humanities but it could have been in
something else
so philosophy courses tend to be
self-selecting in other words you tend
to see a better better group of students
well you know that this is not the
easiest subject to talk about especially
if you're just kind of on the periphery
and i guess what i'm leading up to is
when do you see students really kind of
kick in and start to
enjoy this subject and and how do they
get there what do you do to
interest them right that's a very
important question obviously i've
devoted my life to thinking about it i
think the most important thing that that
i would uh
say is it is necessary to show students
that philosophical questions emerge
directly from their everyday life
in other words if one presents a kind of
technical uh
series of lectures using very fancy
terminology
and talking about extremely abstract
topics like the one in the many
the nature of being
the relationship between being a
non-being and so on and so forth or even
if one begins by saying that well
philosophy is about the structure of
knowledge and in particular scientific
knowledge and we have to learn how to
deal with concepts and logical systems
that's fine for graduate students but it
doesn't work with the undergraduate
who's there to fulfill a humanities
requirement on the other hand if you can
show these kids that the things that
they are deeply concerned about
like what this what should they do with
their lives what is a correct moral code
how do they stand with respect to their
religion
uh that kind of thing if you can do that
in language that they speak not in
professional jargon then it's really
quite uh astounding how
the fires of philosophy begin to burn in
their souls but it's got to be done in
that kind of semi-colloquial way
otherwise it doesn't work
why do you think
socrates and plato have survived all
these years
well
one part of the answer is this
plato was perhaps i'm just going to
state this in an unqualified way but i
think most many perhaps even most of my
colleagues would agree with me plato was
the greatest artist and writer
in the sense of uh master of prose of
all the philosophical of all the members
of the western philosophical tradition
most philosophers can't write very well
i mean by literary standards you know
it's no fun reading hegel or leibniz or
immanuel kant among the moderns
aristotle uh depends what you're reading
but
many of his writings are extremely
technical plato of course wrote some
very technical dialogues but on the
whole reading plato is comparable to
reading shakespeare
or dante
or let us say one of the great greek
tragedians now i don't mean to imply
that there are no substantive
differences between the platonic
dialogues and these works of art but the
central answer to your question is that
plato was a great great poet a great
artist
okay this is not related so much to
poetry as it is to everyday use of
language here now in the 20th century or
soon to be the 21st century when someone
says they have a platonic relationship
with another person right where does
that phrase come from
it comes of course from uh
plato's interpretation of the human soul
as erratic
as marked by eros which means literally
sexual love or passion
but
the photonic presentation
of the doctrine of eros in the dialogue
the symposium
uh
represents the differences in
types of human beings
as uh in terms of the degree to which
their erotic appetite
moves upward from the body
through to beautiful works of art
to
productions of science and uh
finally culminates in pure
in the in the vision of the pure
so-called platonic ideas what we could
call the eternal forms that constitute
the structure of intelligibility of the
world a platonic relationship that is
one in which the physical eros the
sexual eros has been transformed as
freud would have said who was not
uninfluenced by all of this sublimated
in other words the sexual eros must be
sublimated to love of the soul and the
love of the soul must in turn be
sublimated into love of the objects of
the soul namely the eternal beings or
forms that he called ideas
so if someone has a platonic
relationship we think it means
non-sexual that's correct that's correct
there can be a and
and certainly would be a component of
sexual desire in this from plato's
standpoint all human relationships
contain a neurotic element i i don't
want to again uh oversimplify but there
there are certain similarities between
freud and plato the great difference
uh is this freud explains the highest
human appetites or human desires in
terms of the lowest in other words he
starts from uh starts from the bottom or
differently stated says well the reason
why we have friends or the reason why we
go into a certain occupation or
the reason why we have uh certain
political or moral views can be
explained in terms of
lower desires which have been hidden
from us by rationalizations plato does
it in the reverse order he says if you
want to understand if you want to
understand sexual love or friendship you
have to understand it as a corporeal
bodily manifestation of the eros of the
human spirit which when purified of the
physical love rises to
the non-physical
uh what we would call spiritual or
intellectual
so that that's the uh
that's correct in other words a platonic
relationship would not be a
fundamentally sexual one but let's not
forget that there is a sexual component
in all human relations from plato's
standpoint professor rosen was born in
warren ohio and he is in boston as we
are talking here on this program for 43
years has been a professor of philosophy
and poetry
and we're going to talk more with him
after this discussion is over but before
we do there just a couple quick
questions what was the difference in age
between socrates and plato
uh one generation approximately
about about
28 years when they killed socrates how
old was he 71.
and how long did plato live
plato lived to
approximately 80 years and when plato
was a student of socrates uh at what
time in their lives was this
in other words was plato just a kid or
no no no no he would i would say he was
approximately you know it's hard to
these things are not known with
precision incidentally but he was
probably in his 20s he was probably in
his 20s now he saw socrates put to death
of course
and where was he put to death uh in the
city of athens
right down there below the acropolis was
that's right yeah he took the hemlock in
the prison cell they accused him the
athenians accused socrates of uh
corrupting the young
and of not believing in the gods in
which the city of athens believed and
then bringing in new gods and how
important was athens uh in in those days
athens was uh one could say the peak of
uh
i was going to say western civilization
but it was it was that it was it was the
most uh magnificent
uh of the political entities
of the fifth and fourth centuries bc it
wasn't the largest the persian empire
was of course much bigger but athens was
the most important of the greek cities
and was the center of philosophy science
art
the techni the arts and crafts and was
also a great political power we're
talking about the period in other words
uh just before uh socrates the period
dominated by uh pericles the great
statesman and athens was at war with uh
with sparta but the war was actually a
much larger phenomenon it was an attempt
by the athenians to maintain
dominance over the uh mediterranean
world at least up until the point where
the persian empire took over so athens
was extremely important i was i'm
tempted to say that uh from an
intellectual standpoint athens was a
kind of synthesis of manhattan and
washington in other words it was the
center of artistic and and intellectual
and literary life but also the center of
political intriguing
and power and the desire for the uh
intensification of uh
the ex the extension of the amer of the
athenian
republic i i started the stammer when i
said that because i don't want to i
don't want to condem american foreign
policy as being simply imperialistic but
i was thinking of the extraordinary
political uh interests in washington uh
which often don't extend beyond the
beltway you know to most americans
and uh similarly the
the extraordinary uh intellectual and
artistic activity in uh
in new york so you could think of athens
as a kind of combination of manhattan
and washington
in just a couple of minutes we're going
to go to
the
politics and prose bookstore and show
this is actually uh an interesting
experiment on our part at c-span richard
hall
is a one-man band producer and
photographer for this program you'll he
he edited it he did it whole he's
conceived it he uh he brought us
professor rosen uh and you'll notice in
this program all throughout at this
discussion that you see from time to
time richard off to the right it's just
a small little detail that 2500 years
after plato and socrates that were able
to do this kind of communications with
one human being uh i want to ask you
just a couple quick questions that will
directly relate to this conversation
when you see people sitting around
talking and there are people that range
in age probably from their mid-20s to
their 70s or 80s in this discussion
group right
do people know what they're talking
about when they attempt
to talk about plato's republic i knew
you were going to ask me that question
i'm going to answer you
honestly uh i was quite struck by the
range of the answers i mean i wasn't i
wasn't surprised because i've been in
this business for a long time
nevertheless each time you see it it's
striking some of the questions that were
put i think were naive but extremely to
the point let me give you a quick
example
one person in the club said i wouldn't
want to live in that city
now that's exactly right if we had a lot
more time to talk i could tell you in
detail why it was not plato's intention
to describe a city in which anybody
would want to live
the purpose of the republic is to show
what price has to be paid
in order to achieve justice that's a
very complicated and subtle thing what
was or what is plato's republic what is
the document the document it's a
dialogue that the manuscript tradition
goes back to the 8th century you know we
don't have the original papyri
but we do have a pretty good tradition
going back to the 8th century
the republic is a dialogue in ten books
uh in which socrates goes down to the
piraeus which is the harbor of the city
of athens with a friend of his who
happens to be plato's brother they made
a group of people all of whom are
dramatically quite interesting but we
don't have time to identify them and
they spend about three or four hours or
perhaps six hours even talking about the
following question which is which leads
to happiness for the individual person
the life of justice or the life of
injustice
and in order to settle that issue or at
least to explore it they transfer the
question to the uh
to the uh the domain of politics
socrates makes an analogy between the
soul of the individual person and the
city and he claims in a famous sentence
that the city is the sole writ large and
then they spend a number of books
investigating a just city and what would
be necessary to make a just city and
then they come back and try to apply the
results of this to the individual soul
that's the basic theme of the republic
you can't see this but i'm holding up
alan bloom's version of the republic of
plato just to show how big it is yeah
and uh the ten books that you're talking
about are within the
covers of this book right which is do
you have any idea how many words it is
or give some it's just it would look
like a standard book you could buy in a
bookstore it would contain all 10 books
it would be about depending on the
translation of i would say about 400
pages approximately 400 pages you and i
are going to come back and talk a lot
more about plato and socrates and all
this after this is over
as we said earlier this was recorded
back in june and july there are a couple
of discussions you're going to see at
this point a 90-minute discussion of 12
people who meet the first tuesday of
each month at politics and prose
bookstore
here at
out in northwest washington and the
subject is
plato's republic our guest that you've
seen up until now is professor stanley
rosen he's in boston as we're talking
today he's from warren ohio as we said
but has been a teacher for 43 years of
philosophy professor rosen we look
forward to talking with you after we
watch this discussion group on plato's
republic thank you very much
book tv recently visited the classics
book group at politics and pro's
bookstore in washington dc
this book discussion group meets on the
first tuesday of each month
and in june and july of this year
devoted two sessions to plato's republic
after the 90-minute discussion we'll
continue our interview with stanley
rosen
the
i think that the republic is interesting
um because you know the first question
that comes to mind uh for me anyway um
and i want to find out what comes to
mind for other folks but for me it is
you know what is it about
what um
what what's the republic about uh it's
it's um
plato
kind of claims that it's about uh
justice and injustice and the uh
existence of justice and injustice and
and what it might mean to live a just
life or or a an
unjust life an injust life um but
uh that's couched in a political fable
of
of what a perfect just city might be
and when we refer to the republic
sort of in common currency certainly
it's that aspect which is at the fore
it's description of political life
rather than its description of the life
of individuals
but there's also a huge amount in here
somebody said i think you said uh
just before that you were getting a
little sick of everybody agreeing with
socrates all the time
and there's there is a huge amount uh in
the republic uh in defense of uh the
socratic method the dial the the
dialectical method um it comes up again
and again from the beginning to the end
of the republic
so another possibility is that it's that
that's one of the things that it's about
the the socratic method itself the
dialectical method itself um it's it's
also
um about that that great uh
you know the the
the
platonic ideal of platonic ideals which
is
um
the the existence of perfect forms out
there that reality corresponds to
um that that also comes up throughout
the book so you know what did people
think of the first the first section
here
what uh
what did you
you know do do you take i guess the the
question is do you take plato at his
word that this is a a book that's about
justice and injustice
i think it is but i don't think he
really
when he starts talking about it i wasn't
sure what he was talking about or how he
def how he defined justice and injustice
because they keep going around to all
the different ways just as injustice
justice
injustice just and just is just i mean
they turn the arguments over and over
and don't end up anywhere and that of
course is when he starts trying to say
okay maybe we can't talk about this as
it applies to the individual maybe we
have to talk about it as applies to the
group and that's when he starts
postulating this city
and the people who would be in it and
i had a little trouble with some of that
because it's very constrained now maybe
that's just the system is extremely
simply each person only has one function
in the city
and he moves on from there to start
defining education as
in very constrained ways
and frankly i sounded sounded to me like
a pretty dull place as far as i got in
this in this reading of it it's not a
place i'd want to be to live under
those kinds of constraints in order to
supposedly achieve justice
it didn't appeal to me
it's the place where i wanted to be
i i was very interested in the the book
one the the
this as a response to the the thrasmus
frazzimakis is that rasamakis's view
which is certainly very much with us
still that that what that might mix
right and that the strong
say what is right and and that's all
that counts
and i think that certainly apparently
that was a common view
although there was some dissent about it
in athens and there's and it's still a
common view and it permeates our society
and it permeates the international
situation
uh one can look at the situation in the
balkans and say that
here's an example of
someone trying to to apply justice
or you can look at it and say well the
the the court in the hague was simply
responding to the to the powerful
and it seems to me i did not get
terribly far i got halfway into book
three so i haven't really got the whole
picture
of how he deals with it as a society but
i think
my impression is what he's trying to do
is to find some answer
to the idea that the only thing that
matters is who the strongest is
and certainly that is a commendable
attempt to try to
find an answer to that i haven't read it
far enough to know whether
his answer works or not
but i'm focused more on that than on the
society
so it's sort of going along the same the
same line i i'm unfortunately i'm not
very far into it but i
you know from a long time ago i do
remember reading plato and earlier
incarnations and
many years ago but
one of the
questions that that came to my mind
in reading it was
the question of what was the political
context in
in athens at the time that plato is is
writing this because he
um
he is
postulating a kind of republic that is
not
not the athenian
model
and he must have found
in the
democracy of the golden age or whatever
it is he must have found some
something very much missing of course
we've seen some of that earlier in the
apology and then
in socrates earlier in the earlier
dialogues
but it's very curious to me how he
how he runs this into into the republic
that that will be
coming up in in terms of
i think as you said a pretty
sterile and and
rigid society that seems quite at odds
with our notions of classical
athenian
democratic flowering and
i wonder what it was in the history
of of athens that led him to be so
disillusioned i almost wish we had read
this before we read the apology and the
creto and all of that about the death of
socrates because when you read some of
this you begin to understand why the
rest of the athenians were terribly
sympathetic to his point of view
because as i understand it i'm not no
authority on greek history but they had
a pretty free wheeling democracy in
which everybody participated no matter
what your role in society was and it
sounds as if uh yeah what is who i am
it did depend on what your role in
society was there was not everybody or
the slaves well if you were always
but as long as you were you know free
white and 21 as they say you did
participate in a society whether you
were a farmer or a plumber or whether
you were a high-ranking individual or a
soldier everybody took part in this
great democracy that they had and it and
must have been pretty unruly i mean when
you look at what the house what the
house does well it's 500 and some
members and you can just contemplate
what what a debate in athenian society
must have been like and maybe it was
just
it was too unruly for socrates to uh to
contemplate because he never really much
participated in it himself if we believe
what if stone has to say about the trial
of socrates so that but that brings up a
good point too as to you which is that
we tend to think of
greece
rather as the uh
the the bed of democracy um and and in
that sense uh we look to it very much as
the the sort of root of western
civilization
politically um and yet uh here's this
very important
uh dialogue by a very important
um
greek philosopher who that's arguing not
at all for democracy
i disagree with you i think he's arguing
against democracy it's how it's going to
work
he doesn't like the forum he has trouble
with the forum
in at this particular at the time he's
writing it's unwieldy
and i think he wants
uh
somehow for there to be more control of
who rises up to the top
and i want to in this
translation
in the translator's introduction on 16
it says this in a few words is the theme
of the republic
quote i was forced in fact to the belief
that the only hope of finding justice
for society or for the individual lay in
true philosophy
and that mankind will have no respite
from trouble until either philosophers
gain political power or politicians
become by some miracle
true philosophers
unquote
and that's where the justice comes in
not for justice is the top but that the
person or the people who are going to
rise to the top and lead
to be in charge of the democracy or
whatever you want to call it
are good people who understand justice
whose every description of justice
now but is that
um
well
let's
i'm not sure that i agree with you i i'm
not sure that that that that constitutes
democracy for one thing oh
no i i'm not trying i don't think i was
saying that but oh okay
uh but
well then then let me let me bring it to
another question because uh to to
constrain it to the books that are here
um
what the that we know that people read
what place does uh censorship have in a
democracy because it it struck me that
it struck me that um i was really
surprised i've got to say i i had read
plato before but i hadn't read the
republic before
i had had avoided it and i've got to say
that when i got to book two which is
very early
in the 10 books and
and he started talking about
the first thing that we need to do in
our just city after figuring out how
many people are going to be there which
is not really and what professionals and
what professions they're going to
represent is
censor what people hear
and then it's two books worth it's two
books really of of censorship i'm
looking at uh
377
a do you is that
yeah how you i mean is that
what blade is gonna what book is it uh
it's in book two 377a
and uh
and he um
well it's it's there that he begins to
talk and in c he says we must begin then
it seems by a censorship over our story
makers and what they do well we must
pass and what not reject
and the stories on the accepted list we
will induce nurses and mothers to tell
to the children and so shape their souls
by these stories far rather than their
bodies by their hands uh and but most of
the stories they now tell we must reject
then he proceeds to throw out homer and
everybody i mean
there's not a whole lot left when he
gets done yeah but i mean that can be
read on on sort of on two levels i mean
he obviously he does take it to for us
to an extreme of of censorship and to
the modern uh temper that's that's
that's not right
but on the other hand what he is doing
is criticizing
um criticizing the uh
uh the media of the day
saying that's right
uh saying that that there's some real
problems with with
with uh with homer and i i think that we
found that pretty well ourselves in
but he also doesn't seem to understand
something very fundamental and that is
it humans won't be good just because you
they deal only with good things
that there is this this threat of people
that has got a badness to it that people
do like this he does deal with that
later on
okay because does he have to really come
to grips with this this constant um
tension in in in the greek literature
the the dionysian and the and and the
apollonian i mean the
which which the the dramatists and
everybody else has always
really stressed this i mean there is the
irrational
imperfect societies okay well i look
forward to book nine because because he
is so superbly rational and at least i'm
up to the end of book two which is all
the further i am now and my recollection
of it very rational
and and totally misses this this this
other streak in human nature which
all the you know the the
the tragedians and the
and the myth makers and everybody else
he seems to think that through
censorship he can eliminate it
you are being too optimistic today
yeah we want to censor pumping violence
into our kids now some people are
talking about that yeah but i mean i
think you're much too optimistic that
the modern temper is against censorship
i mean i think well i mean and it runs
right in this country right through the
20th century well i think it's an issue
rotten stuff together it's it's an issue
it's a it's a genuine issue today as
much as it was then i don't think we are
all of one he casts it in pretty strong
terms
i would like to suggest that maybe and i
i haven't gotten far enough to say this
but that this may be a critique of
athenian democracy and not really
intended to con because it's clear if
they can anyone ever constructed a
society like this it would either be
sterile or it would fall apart in the
day
but
but he is raising issues about athenian
democracy at the time
which are very valid issues about any
democracy and when we came to form a
democracy in this country we didn't
create an athenian democracy we created
a democracy which or a republic with
checks and balances with the senate
which is not democratic and a
system electing the president which is
not democratic the house is the only
really democratic element in our
government and it's not the best part of
the government frankly so i don't think
that canadian democracy is our model the
role of the judges maybe maybe our
founding fathers read plato and looked
at this and said okay maybe what we need
to do is break up this power that that
socrates wanted to vest in this one
individual
and let these various
loci of power balance each other out and
that's of course what kind of a system
they set up whether it works better than
the republic or not of course anybody
can argue survive but it has survived
that's right so far so this is not very
old that's right but i'm not sure that
survival is dependent on the more
democratic elements it may be dependent
on the on the less democratic elements
well this seems like a description of a
perfect society
thought up by somebody who's comfortable
more in his head than in reality
and i think that's where the censorship
idea came from that
i'll think up what's really great and
then we'll get people to do it instead
of looking at what people do and
thinking how can we work with that
and i think later he contradicts that
when he
talks about poetry i know we're probably
not going to talk about that tonight but
he said poetry is inferior because it
only describes it's not reality but i
think here
he's putting more emphasis on the idea
than on reality
um
the
my question about censorship is not to
uh
is not meant to suggest that we don't
have our own issues with censorship but
um it strikes me that this is the
beginning of his description of the
perfect state
and in many ways well he identifies it
as such he says we must begin then with
censorship
and in many ways i i i think he's
beginning then with sentences i want to
know where it says where he says that
okay specifically where he says we must
begin with censorship because i
um there's there's a part in
in here at the beginning that says
that we have to understand
it's in the introduction that we have to
understand that the
there was no formal education
in greece at the time
it happens that makes a big difference
and so
what he's doing is starting formal
education and saying we need to educate
people in order for them to rise to this
position of uh responsibility
and
in order for them to know to be able to
be discerning people and do
what is just and good for the
whole they need to know certain things
now
you want to read that as censorship but
i'd be curious as to
let me see i i see it from that side and
yes he does talk about you know this is
terrible and this is bad in here but as
this also says they didn't have the
bible in but do you remember the part
where he said we have to lie to the
people we have to lie
that
it will be okay for the for the rulers
of this yeah but i think it ought to be
understood in context for what the
situation was then at the time sure with
no schooling at all except for
um a very
certain uh wealthy
whatever wealth was i'm not sure that's
true
because when we were reading
aristophanes it's you know he talks
about socrates setting up a school then
yeah but it's but it's who it's it's not
the street kids it's a very small the
academy
that this well what socrates was doing
was the very beginning but that's what
he was trying to do in the academy but
that's just the very beginning of it and
it's what should be taught in the
academy and
that was new but he talks about
education in greece consisting of the
gymnasium and and music which he would
in which he incorporates all the
literature and all the you know all of
the uh drama and poetry and all the rest
is all incorporated into that and i
presume science as much as they had any
also
um
so it tells me that there was some it
wasn't a school system but people did
learn it it was limited yeah
if this is to be taken as a curriculum
then it's different from if it's state
censorship
and and i'm not for people who've gone
further with this is he advocating i
mean it may be we're present they may
not have been able to conceive
something say we're going to start with
censorship or that's what we're going to
teach you maybe it does but i'd like to
see how it's how that appears censorship
is a very loaded phrase in our society
it may not have been but
he goes through several stories
including stories i mean that were well
known the stories by escalus and he has
homer iliad and the odyssey goes through
what's wrong with them and then says we
must therefore put a stop to stories of
this kind before they breed in our young
men in undue tolerance of wickedness
[Laughter]
i agree with you he is he it's it's
important to keep in mind uh the context
and that he is interested in um
establishing something that hasn't been
established before um and and and it's
also true
formally estab formally establishing
something that has not formerly been
established
and i think that um
and i think that's important to keep in
mind it's also important to keep in mind
that censorship is a loaded phrase and i
threw it out on purpose as such but
my question is not
even in context i think that the
question of um choosing what children
can learn
is
is a loaded topic even when we say
that he is establishing even if we take
the best
which is that he's establishing a
curriculum i think it's a loaded topic
he is interested in
down to
controlling how people talk about the
gods and not attributing to the gods bad
qualities
now
that's very different in my mind
from
um from
establishing a curriculum of things that
it's important for people to know what
he is saying and this gets back uh to
something that you said earlier is that
if we can keep them from hearing about
the bad stuff
and and he's defining the bad stuff
pretty broadly
then we can keep them from being bad
people
on
again on 377 uh b
he says um
hold on
yeah
b he says shall we then thus lightly
suffer our children to listen to any
chance stories fashioned by any chance
teachers and so to take into their minds
opinions for the most part contrary to
the opinions for the most part contrary
to to those that we shall think it
desirable for them to hold when they
grow up he's not talking here about
knowledge because knowledge comes up
later and and he talks very very clearly
about the difference between what
opinion is and what and what knowledge
is and he he recognizes that you're
really we're really only talking here
about opinion um and and and here too
he's saying uh and and i guess that's
what's at issue for me is um
is controlling opinion the same as
controlling
uh
setting a curriculum
well i i
no it just seemed i mean it seems to me
that we're really getting at the root of
of of what this is about because
the underlying assumption
of a democratic uh form of government is
that through discussion through the
inner the marketplace of ideas that the
the best
solution for for the the for the body
politic will arise now nobody
you know the in our own jurisprudence we
say that uh freedom of expression
doesn't mean that you can call fire in a
in a in a crowded theater
so there are limits upon upon free
freedom of expression and upon the free
free market of of ideas and and
even in our own
concept and certainly i mean this is
after all the end of the 20th century
and and
we saw what happened in the weimar
republic we know that that
there are dangers in in in democracy
that it can swing in the wrong
directions but i think what is
significant in in
at least what i've read so far in plato
is that he doesn't give any credence to
that interplay of ideas he is not a
relativist and i think that there's a
certain amount in the democratic uh
ethos uh theories that says things are
relative that my opinion is as we you
just mentioned opinion my opinion is my
opinion your opinion is your opinion and
may the best opinion
after we talk about it when and reach a
consensus on what what would be right
opinion and that's about as far as we go
in our modern world
but that is not that is not plato's uh
plato is is is much more of an
absolutist
and uh much more directive so i think
that that these these are
it's more than just a question of
curriculum i think there's some basic
theories of of uh
of the body politic here yeah what we've
learned in the 20th century we've
learned that when uh
only one opinion and who's to decide
what it is
uh uh
sways everything and decides uh what our
kids are gonna read and everything uh we
have uh the third reich we have the
soviet union uh
it it to me it's as it's as if
in a practical application this is
almost a primer for the for the third
reich or or the former soviet union paul
what would we do with the children's
book uh in the school library that held
hitler up as an as a
model
wouldn't we ban it
some people would yes would we not ban
it would people feel
ultimately we'd have to come to a
decision as to whether to permit it
in our educational in our school system
and i think it would probably not last
a book that had that that said hitler
was right
the certain groups of people should be
exterminated i don't think we'd permit
that at least i hope we wouldn't
what the age group was third graders
know but if they were
but again we're talking about it
i'm talking about children that's kind
of a it's a it's a very good example
because it points out too though um that
that plato is talking about he's
projecting
his idea of a perfect state now a book
that said that hitler was right uh a
children there are plenty out there but
a children's book that said that hitler
was right um is not
is not
envisioning the future it's it's
justifying the past and we know the evil
of hitler
already uh which is the difference here
is that he's not he uh plato is and and
why it may be more i mean of course i'm
excusing our society over plato's
plato's ideas in the republics but but
it may be more it's easier to make those
kind it seems to me easier to make those
kinds of decisions when you can say well
hitler may have been right but he you
know murdered six million
eight million and uh and so instead we
we say
you know you can read this when you grow
up
versus saying well you know we know that
the gods don't
really shift their form into bulls and
therefore we won't um we won't allow any
of those fables that talk about zeus
shape-shifting um or zeus tricking
people
how about allowing the issue about
teaching creationism is science
uh are we are we is that does that
i mean do we is that something to be
debated uh
that that in in
sixth grade that the world was actually
created in seven days four thousand and
some odd years ago
are we going to teach that that's
we know that that's not so i i think we
should teach that we know that that's
not so and if some group wants to go off
in church and somewhere and teach the
other version
that's okay but you can teach it
historically that people used to think
that but i don't think we should in
public education paid for by the
taxpayers
teach
scientific stuff which is absolute
nonsense well there you have ideas being
presented as science and plato was
presenting ideas as ideas i was just
thinking i wonder why this lasted so
long when i disagree with it so much
it sounds so alien to democracy and the
things i believe in and i think the
reason is that i don't even think he was
trying to establish anything and if he
had established this i think we would
have
seen it
as something we didn't want and we would
be talking about it the same way as we
can now talk about hitler
he failed when he tried to when he tried
to advise a state total he was trying to
do if he wasn't trying to establish a
different i don't think he was trying to
uh to advocate democracy at all i think
he was advocating government by the best
and i never could figure out how those
best were to be chosen and that was
something that disturbed me very much as
i was reading we have these guardians
where are they coming from who picked
them they're these wonderful people
they're going to have all this power
sounds great if it works
and if he had if it had really been
established we would have found out
probably that it worked terribly and it
caused much suffering and pain because
we didn't have ideal creatures we had
human beings and that would have made
all the difference oh
it seemed to me um and i only read
chapter two and five so i'm sort of but
it seemed to me like he was taking us
through the process of examination
of philosophy of government
censorship if you will that and this is
a process that you evaluate and think
about what this is not whether it's
right or wrong but how do we arrive at
that analysis of what's going on that's
that's what i got out of it i
and i think i i said earlier that i
think that all through
um this
all through this very long work
he is uh he is
not just defending his method but
actually arguing for his method
and and and and what you're saying i
think is true that there is um
that there is an element to this that is
um
educational insofar as it's an ex just
an examination of these ideas um on page
uh 336 book one section three i'm not
sure what these numbers refer to but
did it say in your i think they actually
make them universal i mean i can find
what you're going to find in my vlog so
okay so 336 um there's a couple of
interesting things um
about 336 the first thing um is that
this is where you get uh
thrasymacas i'm very bad with them
rasamakis marcus sounds good
rasimi might make makes right
paragraph c um he he just he leaps up
and he attacks the socratic method he
balled out into our midst what
balderdash is this that you've been
talking and why do you simple simons
truckl and give way to one another
um
he says you know socrates don't merely
ask questions or plume yourself upon
converting any answer that anyone gives
but but you yourself give answers and
and he sort of brings that up and
this whole section actually i found
fascinating because uh socrates responds
and when he responds he he says you know
i was so dismayed that if i hadn't been
looking at him right before he spoke uh
i wouldn't have been able to respond at
all uh and and and i when i heard him
was dismayed and looking upon him was
filled with fear and i believe if i had
not looked at him before he did it me i
should have lost my voice but as it is
at the very moment when he began to be
exasperated i glanced at him first
and and there's something
what's interesting to me about that is
that there's something very personal in
that for me um and it's something that
comes through i think in these dialogues
quite a bit um the in in the the idea of
the socratic method which is very
different than our own idea of education
and to get back to the the example of a
curriculum
another way of thinking about
the idea of censorship is that plato
isn't
just talking it seems to me about trying
to keep bad ideas away from people but
he's worried that bad people will be
transmitting those bad ideas and um and
for him education is something very
personal and even the teacher even
socrates you know has to be looking at
the student and has to have that
connection
um but then
it continues to be interesting because
337
thrasymachus uh comes out and says you
know here we have the well-known irony
of socrates and we've just had this
paragraph which is the most personal
glimpse of socrates we get the whole
evening um you know i i i have read the
whole thing and this is the most
personal he is saying that he trembled
in fear he couldn't he couldn't speak to
this guy without looking at him and then
thrasymachus turns around and says um
you know this is irony he can't be he
can't be telling me the truth um and
that when i went back and and
you know it was one of the sections that
i had marked and so when i went back
after finishing it and reading it i
thought you know what is the
relationship of irony to this whole
thing which frankly i found horrifying i
mean the the whole of the republic i was
not
on socrates side uh everything in me
rebelled against what he was talking
about and you know then i came back to
this passage here and i thought you know
wait a second what is the relationship
of of
socrates to irony and of the republic to
irony is it all a big send-up are we
supposed to come out of it in other
words the question is are we supposed to
come out of this and and i don't i i
don't know but are we supposed to come
out of this and say you know wait a
second
wait a second
this isn't right
to me this whole republic is just a
vehicle for getting people to think
about what things really mean it's just
a vehicle and i don't know if he
believes in it or he cares about it but
it's an example he said let's take this
it's like the devil's advocate he could
take either side i really believe
and and just start an argument
um the translator's notes say
periodically as you go through this
edition
don't take this to heart don't take this
part too seriously you know
think what plato is trying to do here
and don't take it word for word
it gives you
i find lots of caveats in here which
actually makes it a lot easier to read
because you stop being quite so stunned
horrified
and upset and so on as you go through
and just for the translation you have
they don't use the word irony in here
they use
uh thrasymachus laughs sarcastically and
replied there you go with your old
affectation socrates interesting
interesting maybe we should be reading
this who is the translator of that
just oh please is that right desmond lee
and your translation is andrew uh paul
shorey
right it's the loeb classic live
classical they're really good things i i
really
desmond lee
um it's penguin classics is the one
um
it took a lot of
i never had a philosophy course in any
of my
lack of schooling
and so this is new ground for me and i i
found that the notes that go along with
this um that each
chapter book heading
has enough of an introduction to give
you the core of what it's about and then
as it goes through
it says uh in various translations it
actually means this and it has all these
connotations to it so if you're not
reading it in greek you can see when it
says and you know the mind or the skill
or and it'll take certain words and
define them out and say it's very hard
to give a direct translation for the
greeks it meant
any one of the following things does it
do this in the
as you're reading as you're going along
yeah yeah it's the it's the notes
is that the entire yeah
when you think about the role of of
plato in the history of philosophy and
in terms of metaphysics uh as the
idealist philosopher who said that
reality you know
reality is here and appearance is here
and
much of that is
the whole history of metaphysics and
western philosophy stems
uh largely from from a lot of what plato
has written but i think what is
interesting was that
that here in the republic you have those
those
ontological you know what is the meaning
of existence what really exists what
doesn't so forth and so on and you have
that cast though in in a political
science
mode which is i think that's what's kind
of
puts us all a little bit off and maybe
that is as you say the the irony part of
it is that he's playing with these uh
metaphysical ideas in in in the context
of athenian democracy at the time which
he's not comfortable with it's not
perfect it isn't perfect so he's
postulating this other republic which i
think perhaps
i mean we certainly don't think it's
perfect and maybe he didn't either maybe
this is all as you say kind of an
ironical setup
but his real
the real message that he wants to carry
through is and is more in philosophical
terms of reality
uh the ideas epistemology the theory of
knowledge
how do you pursue knowledge uh the the
process of the dialectic a lot of other
things and that that his political
science is really kind of
kind of weak and weird
as a result well that brings another
thing to mind that i
uh had a thought about when he um wants
to
not have the children
learn
uh or young men
learn about the um
the myths and the poets and he wants to
throw out homer and
have the gods treated differently or
seen differently and so on
i think at this particular point in
greek history there was really a big
uh
current of undercurrent of thinking
going on
i mean it comes out in some of the plays
questioning exactly who are these gods
you know do they really do this
is this really the way it is and
i think that there was a lot more that
was affected in the larger geographical
area of coming and going of ideas of
and that it is something we
or at least i don't know
i i know a tiny little nibble about it
enough to make me curious
um
but i think that that's part
of why he wants to throw out homer the
children can't hear homer in the poets
but as the introduction says that's all
they had they didn't have as we have the
bible as our kind of book
um
that was their bible the iliad the
odyssey
and uh were their bibles and then the
plays that in the escalators euripides
that had just been in the previous 75 or
so years been presented and all the
poets were
that's all they knew and there was this
big period of change maybe that's why
those poets or those playwrights maybe
that's why the plays got written at the
time they did get written and were as
popular as they were it was because they
dealt with all these issues
and then along comes socrates and plato
who's going to write about it because
socrates as far as i know didn't write
he did not right yeah
well that also ties in with our reading
of the fetal remember
where you start getting these
glimmerings of
of theological glimmerings of uh
that go far beyond so i mean it is
really
i mean the sense that you have is plato
is thinking on a broader
history of ideas
plain then
things are not going to be running amok
so much anymore poseidon can't throw up
the sea is this really true that
poseidon
well he uses both terms he uses the gods
sometimes and god sometimes which has
got to express the transitional period
yeah which happens in the place
yeah the idea of i mean a monotheistic
idea was sort of creeping ins
well it certainly was creeping in the
rest of the world there's no reason why
it wouldn't have seeped into greece as
well
um
your i think that's a very interesting
reading and and as far as the history of
philosophy goes maybe puts plato closer
to nietzsche than uh than people had
supposed well that's greek to me
well nietzsche's nietzsche's you know
god is dead um
uh
point of departure i guess i don't see
him saying no no that's a big leap
the reason i bring it up is because i do
think that he is
um that plato is uh
he's playing
well i would fast and loose is not right
but he's playing fast and loose with uh
with received ideas in a way i think
that hasn't been done before and and you
know you pointed this out his rejection
of homer is um
uh it's huge that's a big deal you've
got to assume that that is yeah that is
a scandal
um and and that is uh and it does put a
different spin on this um
as a uh and on what he might have been
trying to do with it as well
i think in light of what you just said i
think it's significant that there are so
many points of view represented in in
this evening the the religious is there
the cynical businessman is there
and they all get to say they're a thing
but socrates wins
no i don't remember equities
[Laughter]
i
see
the thing being justified in two
different ways one is that his
ideas he these were new ideas he was
throwing out and he did not have the
experience of
of those attempts that had been made for
a small oligarchy to rule although they
had had an oligarchy i guess in the past
that had been overthrown by the
democracy but it wasn't the kind of
created
he hadn't had the soviet union to look
at it was probably close to this in a
way
the other thing is that it can be
regarded as a critique of the system
that he was living in of the democratic
system and it seems to me that that
helps to show why it's still relevant
because not that we should replace
our democracy or any other democracy
with this but the but the weak points
are pointed out
and the the inability to tr i mean what
what are you gonna how are you gonna
educate children
are you going to teach children that
that
solving problems through violence is an
acceptable way to do it by saturating
them with violent material that's still
a relevant question and then the the
standards that are lived up to or not by
politicians is relevant
how do we select the people who are who
are our leaders that's still a relevant
issue and i don't think we've solved
that entirely
you've noticed entirely we haven't even
solved um you know do we want our
politicians to do what the people say
you know follow public opinion polls or
do they want we want them to have a mind
of their own
we haven't sold that yet and plato
raises that question
um
just i wanted to go back briefly at
least to um
question of whether or not he's trying
to be ironical in this development of
the city and
ultimately disagree i don't think he's
attempting to be ironical but i also
don't think that he's seriously
asserting that this is a city we should
attempt to develop i believe at some
place he says in order to do it you'd
have to kick out everybody under eight
or something like that
um so that gives you a hint that it
might be kind of difficult to do
right yeah sorry you're right kick out
everybody started
so yeah obvious that it's
you know
he can't be serious it almost seems
when you start with that premise
um
also he's claiming that the place will
ultimately have to be led by a
philosopher king
who
everybody has their own appetites of
their own things that drive them and you
have the you know the lower class which
is just wanting goods and so on you have
the spirited class which is into
fighting and that sort of thing well you
have to find an individual who a
philosopher lover of knowledge
who the reason that they run the society
in a perfectly just way
is simply because they so much enjoy
philosophizing and they know that if the
society isn't run perfectly well then
they're just not gonna be able to live
life the way they want because look what
happened to socrates he got killed you
know when you had this non-perfect
society from plato's perspective so i
don't think we should take it as he's
trying to achieve this
but it's not ironical
in reading each part
for me it's just lessons about different
aspects of human nature right now what
you can expect from a leader what are
ideals for a leader what are the
different parts of the human soul for
everybody not just for
individuals in different it would be
interesting to see what we came up with
that we decided to sit around this table
and devise a perfect society
i think he came up with the best answer
don't tr don't try
[Laughter]
because his
and i could be mixing up aristotle and
plato here but i believe it was
plato who
or you can have government by the few by
the many or by one
the very best regime is an ideal one run
by one the very worst regime is a
tyranny run by one
then by the many and by the few you have
the second best and the second worst and
democracy is both third and fourth um
the variations of democracy so it's you
know if you're chill yeah yeah right
exactly you know it's the best that we
have um i think it's also interesting to
re to consider that
the way this dialogue is laid out it's
probably not the way these discussions
really took place at the time they took
place in other words
this was not really set up as a
discussion amongst five or six people
that small city in the per small area
the parisis you know somebody just
dropping in for lunch and deciding to
have a philosophical discussion i'm sure
that socrates discussed all of these
issues every day on the streets of
athens and they got bandied about quite
a bit
and so therefore it was not a closed
discussion it was spread out through
many more people that were participating
allegedly in this dialogue by plato and
so it made this this may be the reason
socrates was brought to trial even
though it doesn't even really doesn't
really come out any apology
or any of those places where he's
defending himself if he was banning all
of these ideas around the streets of of
athens which i'm sure he was it's no
wonder he went to trial
and that the anthony and society they
didn't want him around anymore
and that's why i think it probably would
have been a good idea to read the
republic before we read the apology
and those others because you have a
better understanding of what plato was
about after socrates was about after you
read this well
from the other
and you raise it in that slip there at
the end that uh you get a very good idea
of what plato is about or rather what
socrates was about it's a big question
it's a big question for for um classical
scholarship it's a big question for
philosophy um and it and it continues to
be a question
and the question is
what
is this plato or is this socrates
it's certainly presented as if these are
socrates's socrates ideas but uh but
plato's the guy that we really refer to
as being the great philosopher
socrates died for his philosophy
in at least one
story of it but
um
the question is
um is this all invented
i mean the idea of the
uh well
that
that is a that's a question um but but
certainly the question of whose method
is being represented here is that
we we refer to the socratic method of
the dialogue but is it
but the evidence that we have is that
it's the it's it's at least the platonic
method it may also have been the
socratic method but it's at least the
platonic method but i i just think that
it's it's worth um thinking about
whether or not we take this
character in plato's dialogue to be
the driving force behind that dialogue
is or
the dialogues is socrates the person
whose ideas these are or are they
actually plato's who is putting them
into the mouthpiece
of socrates there's a an interesting
postcard i i don't have a copy of it but
um
uh an interesting postcard that
has a picture of plato and socrates with
socrates sitting down writing and plato
behind him whispering into his ear
telling him what to write
and that and it and and it sort of
perfectly encapsulates the question
which is you know who was whispering
into whose ear um and how to and how
does that change how we might think
about uh this it may not change it at
all but it may also raise some
interesting questions so
this is skipping around a little bit but
back to
i'll say socrates
um when i read this he's talking about
and i don't have the book that you have
he's talking about justice and it says
does not wish to seem but rather to be
and then he talks about
he will be crucified and know that one
shouldn't wish to be
but to seem to be
just and i think that socrates
was
just he didn't seem to be because he
lived out his philosophy
to the end it wasn't just
talk
cheap talk but he was what he believed
if this if you believe the story which i
like to believe so
you're going to be just you have to take
action and there's no evidence that he
ever acted in anything whoever says you
have to take it
to me justice means you make rulings or
you make decisions or you you know you
act in some way but he did he didn't you
start the academy
started
he launched a lot of ideas
but he went around teaching yeah yeah
in the industry
it seems to me that his concept of
justice was to stand aside
and comment rather than to take any
action and i'm not sure i agree with
that he died for his belief he refused
to leave i think that was one of the
things that plato was was talking about
in his discussion of justice
socrates did the just thing
on behalf of his beliefs instead of the
just thing on behalf of himself
which i think was a um
as a is the description of a philosopher
that's right but not necessarily but in
the apology he could have he could have
uh
saved himself there and he didn't he he
very specifically at one point i'm not
sure what being a just person is about
though that's what i'm saying yes he
lived for his ideals whatever they were
but i'm not sure that that's is that his
idea
you know but i'm not sure that that's
that's justice necessarily justice is
treating treating fairly amongst people
to me i mean to make sure everybody gets
a fair shake
and that that object doesn't really that
discussion doesn't come up here so maybe
the greek use of the word just has a
totally different meaning in the way we
look at it today
than just uh judges and justice also
comes back into it um
not not to to stop this conversation
because i think it's it's a very good
one and in fact it's it's a criticism of
of
the republic as a whole that it presents
a certain view of justice that may not
in fact be what we want justice to
conform to it's not ours but justice
does come back into it um
later at a later point um when the the
switch is made back from the city to uh
the person
i guess we have to keep it
and plato also makes the point that you
cannot have a thing until you have the
idea of the thing so you cannot have
judges and courts until you know what
justice is which to me socrates life
told us what the idea of justice is
it doesn't come to me that way
going back to your question about how
much is socrates and how much is fico
this struck me as being of the things
we've read more likely to have been
worked on worked over by plato a lot
maybe because it's so long
but it also seems to be so much more
literary
than the shorter the shorter dialogue
seemed to be
to me at least to be closer to what i
could imagine an actual conversation
going on maybe that's plato's artistry
but certainly this is
more like a philosophical book than it
is a dialogue
okay
i'm curious whether
have have people here read uh much or at
all of aristotle i mean i know nothing
yes yes yes
it's it's awful hard reading but when
you think about
aristotle coming along later and and
knowing of plato
knowing of
the platonic philosophy and so forth
it's really a shame that it's not more
accessible to read
uh aristotle and find out what he
thought about these kind of things in a
more
accessible way read him because he's not
a good writer
he's a good thinker he's a good player
there may be some parts of aristotle we
should read he wrote something about
history of athens and it's democracy
that might be reading the poetics
exactly
he's a great psychologist too and his
one on tragedy is very good no i mean
you know his his
i mean his influence on on on the
history of ideas is enormous and it was
his his influence on that was really in
the sense i mean plato was the foil for
for aristotle
and led to the whole
history of western thought well
aristotle and it's academy i vote for
reading
i just wonder if there's somebody some
secondary source that anybody that
somebody once wrote a book about reading
aristotle i can't remember the name of
it now though i want to go back to
justice you want to go back to yours
okay um
because i i
i came went back and found the note in
this translation
it says the greek word translated as uh
is commonly translated as justice
which is the main theme of the republic
but justice
is a thoroughly unsuitable according to
certain people a thoroughly unsuitable
word to use as a translation of the
greek word okay
has a less legal and more moral meaning
than justice it is in fact the most
general greek word for morality both as
a personal quality and as issuing in
right action
so
lydell and scott translates the
corresponding epithet as observant of
duty to god and man righteous and it
goes on a little bit more justice right
action just right so on and so on it's
it's
just you know it's very for us it's just
sort of like virtue and beauty and all
those things there's another note on
virtue in here and where they use it and
they say what yeah you know the greek
word for virtue
we say virtue here but it actually this
is this is it there is a quality that
has a broader meaning and brings in some
other things too this all reflects the
fact that that plato was was was a uh
was a was an idealist and he was looking
for the the ideal the pinnacle
whatever it is up there that is just
that is virtue that is but the english
words we use in translation that we take
with
yeah and we just we take with our
context of today
is not necessarily really the context of
of the 400 bc maybe we should all be
reading alan bloom's translation which
he he swears is literal right word for
word for the greek well this this says
there is no right word what does he say
about justice um i don't know i don't
have that immediately
but that
even without a translator's note i i do
believe that that meaning of justice
that you just read comes out in the
discussions you can see that they're not
just talking about a narrow meaning of
the word particularly in book one i
think
i mean when they're talking about the
just and the unjust man i think that uh
that the idea that this is not they're
not talking about law they're not just
talking about duty they're talking about
they're not just talking about fairness
no they're talking about some sort of
amalgam of these things although i do
think that notice is um but one thing is
whatever it is is is an absolute it is
it is the pinnacle of something out
there in the in the blue sky and that's
where i think it's interesting if you
contrast what what errors and what
little i know about aristotle and we all
know the aristotelian mean that
everything should be at at a mean you
don't go to the extremes and here's
plato going
straight to the furthest
yeah could i just throw in something i
think the the going back to the
thrasymachus is the the fellow at the
beginning who clearly doesn't believe in
anything any standard uh that you can
hold up to people's conduct
uh and it may be in the blue sky but
plato and socrates
are
attempting to persuade us that there is
a standard
which is an absolute standard against
which human conduct can be judged
and that's certainly an honorable
enterprise whether they succeeded or not
yes because i believe that if without
that then we're driven back to thr then
then it is the powerful that rule
and and what they're saying is it
doesn't matter whether the powerful may
win in the given situation they're still
wrong
and the question is can you say that
when the powerful crush everybody around
them they're wrong
and if you don't have a standard in the
sky in my view you can't say that
it's whoever whoever wins whether it's
in business or
in the military or any politics
let me uh let me sin since we're we've
we've only read the first part we're
only discussing the first part let me
let me ask you guys a question because
it strikes me that part of the confusion
here around the idea of justice but also
more in general is in the
move that socrates makes from
the individual to
well i'm not quite sure what a just
individual is and it would be difficult
for me to describe one but let me
describe a just city which is
after all just a larger just individual
and it comes up again and again
throughout throughout the dialogue
this this dichotomy between on the one
hand a person and on the other hand uh
um the state
uh the city state
is that a i mean is it a
he clearly he clearly finds it a useful
um
device
and a useful distinction but i i think
it throws
it confuses things an awful lot um and
and i wonder whether or not how other
people do you feel like it's
that you can make that that you can make
the the leap what is what we can
describe about the city we we also can
say about its individual citizens he
makes a statement someplace where he
something else
um and i think this is where he gets
away from studying an individual and
looking at the whole
and that that's a higher level of
discourse than if you're talking about
people
i think he uses in my transit things but
that's where i felt it worked
because it isn't the personality now
it's the process
but does he see if we if we find justice
in the state then if we can define it
there then
and to work it from that direction
instead of the other right but that's
not how it that is how he presents it
but it's not necessarily how it operates
in the text
he he speaks frequently of um of
we can see that a
uh just as a city divided against itself
so too a person divided against
themselves
and and things like that which which
which turn it from just
um a search for for what justice might
be into um i think a real uh
analogy that he's dropped
that he's drawing up
well it doesn't stop there he it get
you you do
get into more of the study of the
individual when you start talking about
the soul
here's an interesting quotation from
irwin edmond on the philosophy of plato
it's just on the back of this i just
happen to notice
he says that
according to plato that justice
justice in the individual and justice in
the state
are a realm of order an earthly anagram
of that unearthly eternal order which is
the world of ideas
the perfectly ordered soul the perfectly
ordered state are temporal incarnations
of eternal reason
and i think that's a pretty pretty good
summary of
what plato is all about
in his mind
[Laughter]
this business of using the city as the
example
has
in a way diverted everybody's attention
over the centuries
because from the from this question he
starts out with because certainly i
thought of that a little bit i'd read
before was all about the state and the
political science stuff and that's
that's not what he sets out to do and by
using this as an example he may have in
a way
not done what he really was meaning to
do or maybe he really was meaning to do
that and i think he had a much
introduced it to jeffrey
i think he was being disingenuous when
he said let's talk about the state first
and then i don't think he ever wanted to
talk about the individual but it's
easier to generalize when you talk about
big things and that's what he wanted to
do
yeah i had a little of that too
i caught a little of that too
sometimes he reminds me of colombo
colombo he's very disingenuous he's very
sly he says oh yes i agree yes
but you know that little thing down
there what about that
you know and he'll just pick out some
little um and then make his point
and he's not agreeing with everybody at
all
it makes him a good stylist
more easy to read and more interesting
to read than
theirs yeah but somewhat madney too i
mean every now and then you you
understand why they
had to drink a little cup of hemlock
but
about this this uh this idea of working
from the small up to the big
this is an awfully long thing and he in
socrates talks about an awful lot of of
different subjects and he is never wrong
about any of them
about any of them uh and and it really
uh i mean i mean i think it's
interesting both in terms of the
construction of the argument and also as
a rhetorical strategy uh which well
those two things closely related but but
he builds by such small blocks in this
and yet i disagreed with every large
premise
but his assumptions are outrageous his
assumptions are outrageous
his assumptions are outrageous and and
um and
it
yeah it just raised a big question for
me about the idea of the socratic method
about the the the form of the dialogue
um about building uh you know plato was
so opposed to the sophists who who uh
argued
about nothing for nothing for the sake
of argument and yet this just
stunk of sophistry to me
i mean in place after place and they
sort of come up even even in here as as
uh bug bears to be to be uh warded off
but i i just felt like uh you know
socrates was so careful about picking
he he was like an ant colony building
the parthenon
he never wanted to move a rock he only
wanted to move grains of sand
and uh and you know basically he's he he
got people to agree with every grain of
sand so that so that there was no point
at which people could say when he
reached his conclusion
well no
because they had been saying yes yes yes
yes yes so it made no sense to say no at
the end i think by the time
it was probably a no i mean after you
piled all this up
and got all the secretion together you
know you take a look and you say is this
the way
they really want to form a government
and you say blah no that's not the way
it should be
let me ask another question about the uh
about this government because
uh
because i wanted to ask about what
folks thought because we are talking
about this government here i guess
um in most of the republic and there's
this line that you know one of the lines
that that jumped out at me uh the rulers
that i'm sorry it's um
it's 389
c the rulers then of the city may if
anybody fitly lie on account of enemies
or citizens for the benefit of the state
no others may have anything to do with
it but for a layman to lie to the rulers
of that kind we shall affirm to be as
great as in may a greater than it is for
a patient not to tell his physician or
an athlete his trainer the truth about
his bodily condition
uh
i thought that would the the second part
of that was quite interesting the idea
that uh that it is a great sin not to
tell your doctor what's going on what's
going on um but but also this idea you
know
this is this is again an idea that gets
argued constantly uh in our society what
is the role of of state-sponsored lying
what is the role of
of secret you know the freedom of
information act
um
i was just reading
an article uh today or not rather a
catalog entry and you know we get book
catalogs from all of the publishers
oxford university press is publishing a
book about uh this guy who fought for 15
years to get john lennon's files
released from the fbi uh he had
originally written under the freedom of
information act and they'd sent him uh
the expirated files and some of the
exploration was just
i mean it made no sense that it would be
for reasons of national security so he
you know he sort of went to the supreme
court with this to to broaden what the
freedom of information act
meant um and uh and and that's what he
and now he's written a book about it um
you know which may have been his point
uh all along but um
so it's so it's a current issue uh in a
lot of ways you know what
is it not this this idea that
well
we've already learned that the uh
these guardians or whoever have the
right to lie to people to children and
stuff it's just that individuals can't
lie to them
right
and maybe we hang on to that you're not
supposed to lie in court it's a sort of
big sin
mm-hmm
so i think we generally
generally presume that we're nobody's
supposed to lie to the president
certainly as advisors or not if they
know what
know something about a situation that
bears on it they should they should
certainly advise the president such
i think maybe we don't you know maybe we
don't get so touchy about whether the
president lies back to us after he knows
what the situation is if we had these
just rulers they wouldn't be
doing that sort of thing
no this i think that this is that's his
point it's that the just ruler gets to
lie yes he gets to decide whether or not
whether or not an issue should be lied
about it's part of the job description
that's part of the job
exactly otherwise you don't have a just
state right isn't that one of the
lessons of plato though that is still
valid i mean it really is not possible
to argue rationally that the president
of the united states should always tell
the truth yeah is it i mean we can't
if if we elected the president who
always told the truth we'd be making a
great mistake that's right isn't that
true
does anybody disagree with what if that
if we elected the president
it isn't the answer the answers aren't
the problems it's the questions because
there are some questions that shouldn't
be asked that's probably but they're
also my radical stance is with all the
girls if they're going to mess up would
they shut up about it
you know
don't ask don't tell go be a jerk don't
ask don't don't go tell about it
the fact that we accept the president's
lying doesn't and for reasons of state
hopefully doesn't mean that you that the
individual can lie to the irs
i mean if we're trying to develop
an ideal state we let our president lie
but we don't lie to the irs
i think i don't know that the current
president would qualify as a philosopher
king because he has some real things to
say about politicians
he puts them down
in the category not up here but down
here i think we should probably keep in
mind that he's talking about the the
whole book is largely about the
formation of a society and lies in that
stage
many would argue and i imagine plato
would argue is inevitable um i mean
you know we learn our history you know
the founding fathers and so on and so
forth and not denying there's a fair
amount of truth to it but it's created
into this larger myth and every society
has to have it they you know it it
holds them together it gives them
purpose and so on i think rome's
probably the best one uh in ancient
roman civilization with
the romulus remus thing i don't i don't
know all of it but it's just clearly a
blatant example of just making up a myth
to help construct and con um
hold together a society and if that's
what the rulers are doing either in
creating the founding myths or in some
ways keeping up that image you know for
us our belief that we are generally a
force for justice throughout the world
so
everybody can pick their favorite pet
case where you know we intervene
somewhere and in reality all of us think
it was not a case of justice but we
argue otherwise you know the government
puts it forward as
something that's more noble and it's to
sum it to some
inevitable extent it's necessary
the myths we live by
we do it in our personal lives why not
in our civic lives
you have to have something outside
yourself personally you've got something
larger than the petty
day-to-day
stuff that goes on
don't we
now you sound like shakespeare
stuff he used that word we are stuff
that dreams are made
petty pace
well uh it's it's nine o'clock um
so
maybe we should break up unless you guys
really want to keep keep calling what
are we reading next time what more of
this i hope
now
if
i want to thoroughly recommend this
version
i just was looking again here in the
introduction
it explains at the very beginning the
translators introduction of the state of
athens at the time that plato grew up
the wars the polyphonisian wars
what the government was the changing
governments and by the time he was 18
what had happened
and so when he was coming into his full
adulthood athens was on a very bad
athens lost it at that point
and was on a very bad downward spiral
and i think that that's important and
this
book besides saying what all these words
mean and giving you caveats all along i
just
if you all have
questions about yeah i think i got this
here that with your translations i just
am finding this enormously helpful
that's the penguin
desmond lee's penguin edition um
it doesn't have lee's name on the
outside of it but it's uh no but it's
the penguins it's the penguin classics
um
second edition revised
but it's the one upstairs
i think we have it and if and if we
don't we can certainly order it and get
it by the end of the week
uh and and at the latest uh right after
the weekend so um now
the the division is it was actually
pretty much in half right um so
so 5 through 10 for next time in
inclusive so um
it's uh
he he
it's much more of the same um it's um
the forms begin to enter into it much
more in the later part of the book um
the the two um
the
the divided there are two uh allegories
of
of reality uh presented by plato one
very briefly it's important it's not
very famous it's called the divided line
um and then the other right after the
divided line the next book begins uh
with the allegory of the cave which is
the you know arguably the most famous
bit of of plato
and but then he takes up in book 10
again
the idea of
of reality and representations of
reality and he's got some uh i i think
some startling things to say his the the
platonic ideal comes up as something
that that in itself is so important to
him that he's he's willing to throw
uh things like say poetry uh out art out
um
in favor of this uh or or maybe not yeah
i mean you you see what you think that's
that's kind of how it struck me so uh it
is an interesting uh and interestingly
the city kind of tails off um and and
the last several books dude
don't aren't very concerned with it so
what do we do for september
september now we'll continue our
discussion about plato's republic with
professor stanley rosen of boston
university mr rosen has written 13 books
and three of them are about plato's
dialogues
this interview is about 45 minutes long
professor stanley rosen who is in boston
and teaches at boston university
any quick reaction to this idea of a
book group sitting around talking about
plato's republic
my quick reaction is that
it's a
this might sound a bit uh uh
flowery or rhetorical but i think it's a
wonderful testimonial to uh
uh the democracy that people can do this
kind of thing without the kind of
sophisticated uh education and
background that one would see in
equivalent groups in some european
countries i i sort of was impressed by
it i mean obviously some of the some of
the responses were very were very naive
but uh many of the people who
participated i think perceived real
difficulties and and brought up
interesting objections
uh to what they took to be plato's
argument where i think they went wrong
is in taking the work too seriously that
is to say they didn't treat it as a work
of art
and one in which a variety of points of
view are being presented
in ways that are going to be meaningful
differently for different kinds of
people they took it as a kind of
monolithic argument you know something
like an essay on civics that they might
have been assigned in high school
saying the same thing to everyone and
meaning
uh everything that it says to be taken
quite literally now that's the wrong
approach to the platonic dialogue i mean
to read that dialogue is you have to
approach it more
in the way that one might approach a
play by shakespeare but with that with
that said i thought that there were some
very shrewd points made i was impressed
by it let me go over a number of
questions that i asked you earlier
because people often come to this
network
at different times and may not have
heard of earlier discussion certainly
who was plato
plato was the uh
as i said before the the
real founder of the western european
philosophical tradition
in the sense that he was the first to
write a body of work
which we believe ourselves to have in
its entirety
and which lays out
the broad subject matters of uh
philosophy uh for the first time when
did he live he lived in the uh fifth and
fourth centuries
uh born in 428 and died in 348 bc
so he's 2500 years ago or so that's
right that's right how
did we get to know him
in the first place where did he come
from i mean in other words he's an
athenian an athenian how did he but how
did he his how did his words live
through all these years much to his
surprise
plato believed that
that history was cyclical and that there
would be periodic destructions of the
cosmos
i don't think he thought that his books
would be read you know for more than a
few hundred years as it happens they
were preserved in the library in
alexandria
and uh we're not in touch with the
complete history you know of the of the
uh
uh the manuscript tradition and the the
study of that is a as a specialty in
itself not mine
our knowledge our direct knowledge of
the text goes back to approximately the
8th century a.d
the oldest manuscripts in paris and
venice places of that sort
so we've had a continuous knowledge of
plato
from those manuscripts and an indirect
knowledge of plato in discussions by
people who studied him exactly as uh
as my students study philosophers in the
university you have any idea how many
students you've taught over the last 43
years
ah
i know i've turned out about 45 40 or so
i don't want to exaggerate on national
television something like 40 phds who
are now most of them you know teaching
and so on elsewhere hundreds and
hundreds probably close to 5 000
undergraduate students i really have
lost track let's just say 5 000 is not
an unreasonable number if you were able
to sit down with plato today
and ask him some questions what are a
couple that you'd want to ask based on
all these years of thinking about what
his words are all about
i would ask him
plato how can i know for sure that you
believe what you're saying how can i
distinguish between the rhetorical parts
of your dialogues and the parts that you
are uh stating for the good of the human
race things that you want us to believe
so that we won't be miserable and things
that you actually understand what did he
think of religion
that would be one of the questions that
i would ask him
i'm going to give you again a short
answer to a long story i think plato
believed that there was a divine
spirit
visible in the cosmos i don't think he
believed in personal gods of the sort
that
we know from greek mythology
i think he believed that there was a
difference between good and evil that
there was a force of good and the force
of evil sounds a little bit like star
wars
but uh i think you find that kind of
thinking in plato
that there is there is a kind of of
divinity in the cosmos but i don't think
plato believed in personal immortality i
don't think he believed in personal gods
that's my own view what do you think he
would think of uh
this discussion we've been having over
the last couple years about bill clinton
he would have been absolutely horrified
uh i mean not that that not that bill i
take as you're referring to bill
clinton's famous peccadilloes with uh
with ms lewinsky yeah just this whole
discussion about what is character and
morality and all that
plato would have said this is typical of
a democracy
that sounds very harsh to our ears and
i'm actually thinking as i say that of a
lady on the
in the book discussion who said she
thought that
plato was actually defending democracy
i'm afraid that's not right plato is a
great enemy of democracy and one of the
things that he held against democracy is
that it brings forward leaders of
corrupt character
that it's the nature of a democratic
regime that it cannot produce noble or
gentlemen as rulers
that their personal characters are
flawed by
mass media mass markets
massive audiences the need to appeal to
the lowest common denominator and so on
so he wouldn't have been surprised at
all he would have taken this as further
evidence
towards the inferiority of a democracy
what would his teacher socrates
think about all this word for word same
thing same thing yeah do they agree on
everything
that's we don't know because we don't
know anything about socrates in his own
voice what we know about socrates we
know from plato and it's clear plato was
not interested in historical accuracy he
was an artist
in other words he would there will be
anachronistic representations in the
platonic dialogues you won't be able to
say oh yes these events clearly mark
this dialogue as having taken place in
the year such and so but more
specifically to your question uh uh mr
lamb
uh some people tried very hard to find
out what socrates himself thought and to
distinguish it from plato we have a
couple of other sources one is a play by
aristophanes called the clouds
and there's another a student of
socrates named xenophon who wrote a big
book called the memorabilia memories of
socrates there are one or two smaller
and less significant things
which talk about socrates but by and
large we have obviously nothing in
socrates own name and so what we think
about socrates arises largely from our
comparison of the portrait of socrates
in plato aristophanes and xenophon
unfortunately they portray socrates at
different times in his life
and so it's not possible to to come up
with a homogeneous picture of socrates
and it's not possible to clearly
differentiate socrates from plato one
last point aristotle makes some comments
he was a student of plato's
and he makes some comments and says
socrates was concerned let's say with
ethical questions whereas plato raised
uh metaphysical questions i would take
that uh
with a grain of salt but it gives us a
slight indication
namely that socrates had less abstract
not quite so complicated theories as
plato had
that was more interested in
problems of everyday life and ethics i
don't want to exaggerate that but that's
the implication that aristotle gives us
i don't know whether you have this
figure or not but how many folks lived
in athens 2500 years ago well actually
about 300 000
uh and only 25 000 of whom were full
citizens
in other words women of course were not
citizens
children were not citizens resident
aliens were not citizens and slaves were
not citizens so when we speak of the
athenian democracy
we're actually speaking of uh of a very
small proportion of the uh of the
inhabitants of the country less than ten
percent
how did they communicate back then
by talking constantly they were very
vocal people the athenians there's a
greek word paricia which means the kind
of freedom of
not freedom in in the political sense
but you know just talking all the time
they were very very big talkers and uh
they're constantly suing each other not
unlike americans they were always in the
law courts they were always arguing
politics there were constant factions
and and quarrels between uh the rich and
the poor uh the oligarchs the few the
few and the and the many so it was a
place of constant conversation
apparently the reverse of sparta for
example the great rival to the athenians
who were as their name suggests spartan
and who didn't talk so much but were
busy exercising and uh and obeying the
laws of the gods
you're originally from warren ohio and i
see on my sheet here that your father
was a pharmacist right was he born in
this country no
no he was born in uh in
in fact i once asked him he died this
year at 97. i asked him where were you
born in poland lithuania or russia and
he shrugged his shoulders and said i
don't know
it was that part of the world that was
changing you know from week to week how
about your mother celia she was born in
russia
and she spent world war one there was
chased by kha'zix
to her her remember her really really
frightening memories of the place my
father remembers russia let's call it
idyllically because he left before world
war one whereas my mother lived through
world war one and and starved and was
persecuted for being jewish and
just in general you know was in the
midst of a very very bad situation how
does a young man who was born in 1929
like you in warren ohio
go from
immigrant parents to the university of
chicago and become a philosopher
teacher professor how'd that all happen
well that's that's the famous glory of
the united states
i mean the opportunity here was uh
was available i i don't know if i can
give you a more specific answer it's
just i can tell you this i was deeply
influenced by my grandfather my maternal
grandfather who was an orthodox jew and
a man who obeyed the laws
as literally as was humanly possible and
who got up every morning at six o'clock
to strap on the phylacteries and the
prayer shawl
and to pray and i as a little boy of
five or six you know would sort of wake
up and he wouldn't even know i was
watching him and i would watch him do
these prayers
and uh he just impressed me tremendously
and i'm certain that he was he was the
initial influence on me sort of turned
me from the frivolous youth that my
nature
wanted me to be to the more serious
professor of philosophy that
love for my grandfather and of course
for other people
turned me into
how many books have you written
uh that's hard to say because some of
them have been a couple have been
revised and some have been reprinted i
guess about 13 or 14 and in general what
kind of books are they
they're books that uh not many people
would want to read
their their their their philosophical
works my first my first book was poetry
actually i began as a poet
and uh i published a book of poetry when
i was about 21.
but uh i was
turned around as they say in the
espionage world
you know there's a there's a greek word
perry ago gay
that's used in the republic
the turning around of the soul i was
turned around from poetry to philosophy
by a man named leo strauss at the
university of chicago
a man of some notoriety today among
people who are interested in politics
and
he had a lot to do with that i before i
met him i thought that poetry was
philosophy
i thought there was no difference
between the two except in the idiom of
the languages
but this man
played a major role in convincing me
otherwise
uh is that an answer to your question
yeah i i wanted to what i was really
trying to get to was uh when was that
moment i mean you know a lot of us went
through college and philosophy was a
struggle and trying to understand how it
all fit in i see what you mean i'm sorry
and at what point did it yeah tricky
trippy and they'd say boy i love this
stuff right
uh
the honest answer is that i
literally have been this way ever since
i was a child i don't mean by that
sitting around and studying plato but
all my life
i've been fascinated by uh from the time
i was a little child
the motivations of human beings why
we're here where did the universe come
from that kind of thing i'm sure there
must be lots of kids who have those
those notions but they were always with
me in other words it's not the case in
my in my case it's not the case that uh
i always wanted to be an engineer or a
professor a lawyer or something and got
to college took a good course and then
said gee this is for me to the contrary
i assumed somewhat pretentiously that i
was a philosopher before i got to
college and i thought that i was
expressing my philosophy and my poetry
and it was only when i got to the
university of chicago that i it was
explained to me how ignorant i was and
how much work was involved in
transforming myself into a disciplined
thinker and i've never finished that
task it's a an extraordinarily difficult
one let's go back to the discussion held
at
politics and pro's bookstore and for us
at c-span it's a little bit of uh
experiment because this whole program
from start to finish
has been produced and scripted and not
scripted because the discussion was uh
was uh
informal and with no script but it's
been put together by richard hall he was
the photographer and the producer and
brought us
professor rosen among other things when
we go back to looking at these
discussions that were held in june and
july
do you ever do that kind of thing in
your classroom where you have your
students sit around and try to work
through all this
yes yes but you can't do that in a class
of 185 people in other words that kind
of thing requires a limited limited
number of people
i i for many years in fact taught by
taking a text let's say a short dialogue
by plato
with 15 students seated around the table
and then we would start
in the old talmudic way with the title
and i would raise the question why is
the why let's say the dialogue is called
fidris fierce is the name of a man in
the who is a character in the dialogue
well if plato called the dialogue the
fidris he must have had some reason for
it can we figure out what that is and
then we would go on from the from the
title to the first sentence and so on
through the dialogue
if there were 10 or 15 uh good students
in the class then we could have a kind
of roundtable discussion
uh so i did follow that form to a
certain extent but you know in a
classroom there comes a point
where the instructor
must know more than the students
otherwise he's cheating them
at a certain point it's necessary for
the instructor to talk and so you can't
have just the continuous exchange of
fragmentary views which are entirely
appropriate in something like a great
books club discussion
the
the
three people you mentioned earlier we
talked a little bit about this in the
setup for the discussion
uh socrates plato and aristotle
socrates you said was killed at age 71.
and plato was his student at what time
in plato's life was he a student
oh roughly speaking in his early manhood
you know 20 to 40 something like that
and when was aristotle plato student
uh
aristotle spent 18 years studying with
plato i can't give you the exact dates
now but it was after plato was already a
rather mature man long after socrates
death and plato had already established
the uh what we would call the university
his academy aristotle were enrolled as a
student there
the the word academy is that something
that was created that word created by a
plato well it refers to an area in
athens it's just a geographical area but
is that what we mean today when we talk
about the academy yeah when we talk
about the academy we're referring back
to the first academy the first
university well i went back there by the
way brian
in 1956 when my wife and i were living
in greece
and it was a garbage dump
and there were goats chewing on tin cans
and it made such a terrible impression
on me that i wrote a poem
which turned out to be my last poem
so that's that's that's the correct uh
uh inference on your part we speak of
the academy in honor of the first
university did any of those three men
socrates plato are asked out a whole
office of any kind
ever no i mean socrates served in the
army he refused to participate in
politics
uh plato
started
his
what can you call it he had a brief
period in which he was associated with a
political regime but i don't believe he
ever held office he dropped out very
soon he was disgusted by uh the
character of the politicians
uh not just in athens but in general you
could say he was disgusted by the kinds
of compromises the lying the cheating
the rhetoric the self-interest
that one had to engage in in order to be
successful politically and he saw no no
point to it and he also was familiar of
course with the fate of socrates
and
felt that any decent man who entered
into the political life and tried
actually to resolve or to contribute to
the resolution of the human problem
would die would be put to death so he
did not hold in the office similarly
with aristotle is there a difference in
the philosophy of aristotle and plato
well that's uh yes i mean the short
answer is yes
aristotle spent his life
arguing with his great teacher plato
and he made certain
radical changes in some of the
fundamental ideas contained in the
platonic dialogues
uh i don't know if you want me to go
into them in any detail now but he did
make certain changes
he was also uh less
daring and and uh adventurous
in in writing on political affairs
there's nothing like plato's republic
and aristotle's corpus even though he
might agree with plato you know on a lot
of things he presents a more moderate
measured
view of the political life and he talks
about ethics
in a way that is accessible to
the gentleman the greek gentleman
whereas plato tends to speak in his
dialogues in more extreme terms and we
also uh you know think of plato as
uh the the father of the the doctrine of
ideas
uh
we could by a philologically incorrect
step but nevertheless one that makes
sense intellectually we could say that
plato idealizes
presents us with ideals of human
behavior but which are so
exalted people like socrates for example
that the average person even the average
decent person could not live up to that
standard aristotle looks more closely at
human beings as they are
still presents us with the kind of
paradigm of how to behave but the
paradigm is one that's within reach
perhaps that's a good way to put the
difference you know as i listen to you
talk about the things that they were all
interested in especially plato um if you
if you've read the fellows papers and
especially the madison work you can see
reference to things like interests and
and and all the things that have have
survived all these years how much impact
did those writings 25 2300 years ago
have on people like james madison and
thomas jefferson and alexander hamilton
and the and the forefathers here well
to answer as simply as possible i think
the notion of the gentleman of the
educated gentleman
uh goes back to plato and aristotle
whether they got it from plato or from
aristotle or even from cicero the roman
roman philosopher
that would vary from case to case to a
certain extent the picture that the the
authors of the federalist papers had
of the gentleman the landed aristocrat
the man who has enough property
so as to have sufficient leisure to
acquire the kind of education that will
qualify him to be a responsible
statesman
that goes back also to the english
aristocracy you know they were
influenced by people like john locke and
montesquieu and so on but there's the
the english writers in turn were
influenced by the greeks so one can
answer your question very generally by
saying that the paradigm that one finds
the model that one finds in the
federalist papers of it being better to
be ruled by gentlemen well educated who
have some money and property and
therefore responsibility and stability
and who with the
with this money can have leisure to be
well educated and thereby to discharge
their political duties in a way that all
of us will benefit from that's
essentially platonist and it's in its
notion that was taken for granted by the
greeks if you're going to rule you must
have virtue if you're going to be
virtuous you must have been habituated
to be virtuous in order to be habituated
to be virtuous you have to spend your
life doing virtuous deeds and in order
to do that you have to have money
so that's the unfortunate unfortunate
root of that where was the bible
when
back in those days i know it's an
obvious
i mean it's probably an obvious answer
but but at what point when they were
alive uh how far were we away from
having the king james version of the
bible are you referring now to the uh
the founding fathers of the americans no
i'm referring to the you know the yeah
well uh uh
you know there's a legend and i want to
emphasize that this is just a legend
18th century german historians of
philosophy
some of them took it seriously that
plato went to israel in his travels
there was a period in his life when he
traveled he went to egypt for example it
was when he tried i remember i mentioned
he started out in politics as a young
man about 20. then when he became
disillusioned with that he withdrew from
government left athens and traveled one
of the places he went to was egypt and
you'll find stories in 18th century
german textbooks
saying that plato studied with moses and
that's why he was so wise there's no
connection i mean the connection between
the jews and the the the
biblical tradition and the between the
greeks and the bible comes with the with
the new testament uh it's there's no
connection as far as i know between the
the hebrew testament and the greeks
there's some you know everybody's got
theories about everything but i think
i've given you the general consensus
greek philosophy saint paul was already
influenced by some of the later greek
thinkers you'll find elements of greek
thought in the in the christian bible
but the hebrew bible
is quite independent you told us earlier
that plato did not like democracy that's
right what
then would he think of this country
based on what you've read
over the years
he would be very harsh with us
i mean obviously
that's a misleading way for me to answer
the question because it implies
that plato would if he were alive today
would judge 20th century america
by standards of fifth century athens
plato would make two kinds of judgments
if i may dare to speak for him the first
kind of judgment would be to compare the
united states with its contemporaries in
other words to say well the united
states has certain faults but if we
compare it with uh certain countries
which will be unnamed it looks pretty
good on the other hand if you were to if
the second way in which plato would
judge the united states would be as a
democracy
gone wild
and a country in which uh virtue has
been replaced or radically modified by
the desire for comfort incidentally
that's a point that should be made it
goes back to the founding fathers of
this country into the the beginning of
the enlightenment in the 18th century
whereas the greeks believed that only
the good life was worth living right
good in the sense of virtuous
the founders of modernity in the late
modern period in particular but well the
middle modern period the 18th century
of which our founding fathers are apart
believe that it wasn't enough to live a
good life you also had to live a
comfortable life or to put that in a
slightly different way
people who were invoked to live a good
life
would not be able to reach that high and
however highly however high they could
reach would depend upon how comfortable
they were so that they were much more
practical and they modified the idea of
of virtue by comfortable so plato would
condemn that let me let me try to go to
what we know of today in world affairs
and ask you whether or not this is
virtuous
would plato think it's virtuous for the
united states to go after saddam hussein
to protect kuwait or would he think it's
virtuous for us to bomb
over in
belgrade in that area to protect the
kosovars
look
that's a very difficult question
i'm going to answer it
the principle is not difficult to answer
plato was very tough the greeks were
very tough
they had no hesitation whatsoever about
killing their enemies they had no
hesitation at all about that
but
the particular
case of what to do with the yugoslavians
for instance would be for aristotle a
question of prudence i mean by that that
the wisest
men of
the most mature experience
would have to spend considerable amount
of time
weighing the alternatives
by what criteria well with respect to
the on the one hand the interest of the
united states the national interest of
the united states and on the other hand
the principles of moral justice
now that's exactly what we were told was
going on right i mean i i know only what
i see on television and i was told uh by
statesmen and by reporters that there
was an agonizing appraisal of this whole
yugoslavian business uh precisely in
those terms if that's correct if that's
what was actually happening
then that was very much in the spirit of
aristotle let us say and
by extension of plato as well so for
every particular political event
one has to be guided not by some
abstract principle of virtue one has to
be guided by the knowledge that the good
can never be fully implemented
that actual life is so complicated
that you will go wrong if you try to
force a good principle onto all aspects
of the problem and that you have to
simply take the problem apart and try
your best
to decide the consequences of a variety
of actions
so my answer to you is that i can't say
what their particular opinion would have
been of american policy with respect to
the yugoslavians but the procedures that
we were at least told were being invoked
to arrive at that decision those would
have been exactly the procedures that
that people like plato and aristotle
would have recommended there would have
been if i may add one more thing there
would not have been on their part any
kind of humanitarian sentimentality
about killing innocent people they were
very tough i don't mean that they were
vicious but they knew that
when you go to war
you kill people
and if you're trying to survive
uh in the long run it's less
humanitarian to worry about casualties
something that would have been
unintelligible to plato and aristotle is
what i see so frequently on tv these
days namely men in in in uniforms
military men generals saying we mustn't
put our troops in harm's way that would
be unintelligible to plato warriors are
supposed to die for the country you know
i don't mean to sound bloodthirsty to
your audience but you asked me a
question
to which this is a very very appropriate
reply
that would be unintelligible to them so
that kind of consideration namely we
mustn't hurt innocent people
that wouldn't be number one on their
list not because they liked to hurt
innocent people
but because if you're not prepared to
hurt innocent people then you run the
risk of being destroyed yourself
if you've just joined us we're talking
about plato and aristotle and socrates
why here on c-span are we doing this
because this is an attempt at showing
you what a
classic book group discussion looks like
at politics and pro's bookstore here in
washington an independent bookstore
and we videotaped through the direction
of richard hall
two 90-minute discussions held in june
and july of this year in 1999 and our
guest stanley rosen is in boston and
he's helping us
try to figure all this out he's been
teaching for 43 years five years
at boston university and uh 38 years
before that at penn state and he as we
said earlier was graduated from the
university of chicago with a bachelor's
and a ph.d back in 1955 what was your
phd thesis on it was on spinoza's
political philosophy why did you pick
that because my professor instructed me
to do so
he was not a permissive man
i mean today when students come to see
me
who want to write a doctoral
dissertation with me they tell me i want
to write on so-and-so
and i either agree or don't agree but
the man i studied with uh saw things
quite differently and he assigned topics
uh to his students and is that leo
strauss that's right and and why does
everybody rave about leo strauss
why do they rave about him yeah we know
we hear a lot of it here when we talk to
people like you well uh
i can tell you why i would rave about
him he was the greatest teacher that i
ever had
he was a man of extraordinary erudition
wide-ranging knowledge of hebrew arabic
greek latin the romance languages he was
especially good in the history of
political philosophy but he he knew more
than that but he he largely wrote about
that because he was a professor of
political science
he was a man who saw clearly i think
the weaknesses
of late modernity you'll find in strauss
in not quite so excitable pro style lots
of criticisms of modernity that you find
in writers like nietzsche
or which uh uh you would even find in in
people on the left like uh
the frankfurt school
uh a very common uh uh objection to
strauss
some people raved about him positively
others raved about him negatively the
people who raved about him negatively
who hated him
were uh self-styled liberals who felt
that strauss was himself a conservative
and a reactionary strauss criticized
modernity in particular because
he believed that relativism the decline
of the moral tradition of the west
loss of belief in the values of the of
the aristocratic culture of western
europe
uh all of these things were declining
and deteriorating and he was himself a
liberal man in the true sense of the
word he believed in freedom and he was a
great lover of the united states
and he he was anything but a fascist and
a right-winger as he sometimes presented
to be caricature of a right-winger i
know these are tricky questions uh when
it comes to politics today versus uh
other days but let's just say based on
what we think a liberal is today and
based on what we think a conservative is
who would be a conservative's favorite
philosopher today and who would be a
liberal's favorite philosopher well the
liberal's favorite philosopher as far as
i know
remains john rawls from harvard
university
are you made of contemporary philosophy
no i'm sorry i know the old timers oh i
beg your pardon
uh of the old-timers the great liberal
philosopher probably john locke comes to
mind almost immediately
figures of the enlightenment you know
locke in the united states we think i
think we still think very highly of john
dewey he's not read quite as much as he
was 50 years ago but of the great
classical figures
perhaps john locke of the political
thinkers so a liberal would run out to a
bookstore and say give me john locke i
want to read what i think might he might
well you know that
i i'd have to come closer to the 20th
century if you if you put the question
in that way well let me then let me just
go because i want to get back to plato
but let me go to the conservative side
what would be uh their choice edmund
burke
the english political writer of the 18th
century very high on the list of
conservative favorites edmund burke and
aristotle
ranks high because of his moderation and
prudence
uh
there are still some tomist but i don't
think thomas has read again as much as
he was 50 years ago i would i would
restrict myself to aristotle and edmund
burke okay who's yours
my favorite philosopher yes sir
plato
and how do you define him politically
you say he's not for democracy does that
make you not for democracy well i mean
but don't forget that the word democracy
means the rule of the mob
that's another thing that has to be
brought out plato plato uh
one can admire plato
without sharing his political views
one can even share plato's political
principles and see that in order to
enact them under real circumstances in
the 20th century one has to be a
democrat if plato were alive today i
think he would be
on the side of the west in other words
western european democracies i don't
want to say he would be an american
that's a little too self-serving but if
he were an american where would he fit
into our political spectrum or could he
it wouldn't be possible to put him into
one one place or another the
conservatives would like to claim him
for themselves he would he would be he
would look like a uh uh
i would say he would look like a a a
liberal conservative you remember
eisenhower used to call himself that
a liberal conservative a little bit left
a little bit right of center plato would
certainly be in favor of strong
education
he would be in favor of uh high
standards high moral standards in
political office
he would have had zero toleration for
clinton's hijinks
he would have been very much opposed to
the large sums of money
that have been collected by george w
bush or for that matter al gore or bill
bradley he would have spoken in a voice
of moderation against the excessive
rhetoric the empty-headed lying that
goes on on television by candidates the
failure to articulate programs that they
themselves know
are reasonable or have a chance to pass
kowtowing for the sake of election
but most reasonable people would say
would say that in other words i think
plato would have been a man of reason
if i may honor my views with that
title all right based on the discussion
that we watched
and
listening to you tell us about plato if
someone is is
has been uh eavesdropping on this
conversation that's what they're
supposed to do right what would you
recommend they do we're talking about
people that have not studied much
philosophy they may or may not have a
college degree right
they feel a little bit
you know under prepared what book or
books would you recommend that they go
by to start the process of learning all
about this about plato yeah
of course i think they could do uh
much worse than to start with the
republic but the republic is a as
the republic is hard to start with
not because it isn't a wonderfully
written and exciting book
but because uh it sets people off
the harshness and peculiarity of the
details of plato's political program
uh tend to alienate
20th century readers i think myself that
the best way to start with plato is to
read dialogues like the symposium and
the fedris which are human documents the
symposium
i happen to have written a book about it
maybe that's why it's a favorite of mine
is your book available yes it is yes and
can people go online or go to a
bookstore and say i want yes everything
stanley rosen wrote and i wish they
would immediately
how many of those books are in print
uh
all but two or three and they're all but
two or three and those are coming back
into print so virtually all of my books
are in print and who publishes your
books uh
yale
oxford
cambridge
rutledge
and an outfit called the saint augustine
press which is now bringing back into
print
those of my books which which were out
of print i have a small one here that
says plato's
statesman the web of politics by stanley
rosen when did you do that one i
published that in approximately 1995 if
memory serves still
fresh is it useful to a beginner fresh
is a daisy no you know
the beginner would do better if if
they're kind enough to to look at my
books they would do better to to start
with my book on the symposium that would
be that would be what i would recommend
what was the symposium the symposium is
about uh a group of men who are at a
banquet
and they decide not to get drunk which
is what people usually do at banquets i
think drinking banquets and they want to
talk instead and they decide to talk
about love
and the number of different speeches say
a half dozen speeches are presented
about love by a half dozen different
kinds of people
the last of whom or the second last of
whom is socrates and socrates there
gives an account of his interpretation
of love
and talks about his teacher uh a
mythical character named diotima a woman
prophetess and then socrates is himself
exposed by the drunken alcibiades
uh an actual historical character
who who had some dealings with socrates
it's a wonderful extraordinarily rich
document
you could say from this contemporary
standpoint of the the psychology of the
human being and the marvelous
beautiful subtle document about the
various types of love
i would really recommend that dialogue
the symposium how long is it the
dialogue is not very long you know it's
about 100 pages
80 80 to 100 pages do any of us talk
like that today did you could you find a
symposium going on like this anywhere in
this country now
uh you mean of the sort that was held in
plato symposium yes
only in uh
gee i don't really know how to answer
that i i i would say uh largely uh in
professional associations like book
clubs or uh
you know there are there must be uh uh
clubs for example i once lectured in
dublin in ireland
to the metaphysical association and
there were 500 people at my lecture
none of them very few of them were
professors i mean they were just
citizens of the city of dublin and i
assumed that they gathered together and
debated questions you know of this sort
but probably there's not too much of
this sort of thing outside the academic
world let me ask you a couple of
questions and we'll let you go because
you've been very helpful and
generous to your time uh have you tried
to be a great teacher
can one try to no have you tried to be a
great teacher consciously for 43 years
do you do you try to be a and i don't
need to use the word great a good
teacher i mean if you have
what do you think goes into that
i love teaching
i'll put it that way
it's a it's a something that comes
natural to me i don't mean pontificating
or you know just
telling people my views but i love
discussing
fundamental questions
with a room full of lively kids to whom
the discussion really means something if
you don't love the subject you can't be
a good teacher that's that's just out of
the question
secondly you have to be spontaneous
you have to be able to speak
obviously there are times when you want
to give learned papers there are times
when you want to give formal lectures
but you must be able to speak
spontaneously you must have a wide
experience of the different kinds of
human beings you can't other 40
different speeches simultaneously to the
40 different kinds of people in the room
but you have to figure out a way of
going back and forth in your modes of
presentation so as to weave into the
discussion as many of the different
types of people as possible these are
some of the elements that go into being
a good teacher and finally if i may say
so at the risk of sounding like an
elitist swine
you have to be smart and you have to be
competent but the first things that i
mentioned are really essential now let
me go back to that first question have
you tried to be a great teacher
i've tried my damn distress yes i've
tried
and so when is it the most rewarding for
you from a student what do they say to
you that makes you feel like this has
all worked
again
two different things
i perhaps the the most important thing
to me is when i'm walking down the
street
or even at home and i get a letter or an
email or somebody says to me you don't
know me
but i studied with you 20 years ago as
an undergraduate
and may i say this and your course was
the best thing that i ever had in
college that really makes me happy that
makes me ecstatically happy the other
experience of course is when a graduate
student does very well but that somehow
you know that's wonderful and it's a
great honor but it's not quite as
immediately gratifying as having this
kid
someone whom you knew as a kid and you
don't you don't even know who he is now
just step out of the out of the crowd
to use a metaphor
and say i had your course 20 years ago
and i still remember it that means a
great deal to me
before we let you go do you are you
married and do you have children i am
married and i have three children any of
them philosophers
no
only one of them majored in philosophy
and he's now
working in a
health food store in montana he went out
there to work on the environment and
found that there were no jobs there's an
environment and there are a lot of
people who are interested in it but
there's no way to support yourself what
do the other two kids do uh the oldest
boy is a an examiner in the patent
office in washington
interesting position and my daughter was
preparing to be a musician but for
various reasons decided not to continue
and is now retooling as they say what
does your wife do my wife was a
classicist
and uh
taught for a number of years she taught
greek latin french
and english
at penn state university but when we
began to have children she stopped that
i love what your bio sheet says here
stanley rosen speaks french fairly well
italian badly and german he reads
spanish greek and latin
i don't know if those are the way that's
the way you characterize it but is that
pretty accurate well more or less you
know i have a smattering of those things
i'm not a philologist but i use them as
scholarly tools socrates
plato aristotle were they family men
no socrates what socrates is the
exception that proves the rule socrates
was married and had children but his
wife was famous for being a shrew
and for nagging him and he was never at
home he was as we say today always out
with the boys
he's always out talking with his
philosophical friends there's a
wonderful scene either sad or funny
depending upon your own way of looking
at things in a dialogue called the fido
which is about socrates death his last
day of life
he's taken the hemlock
and the poison is moving up his body you
know and he's talking to his friends
about the immortality of the soul and
his his his wife zanthippi is there and
she starts crying and socrates says to
someone else let someone take her home
those are socrates's last words in the
presence of his wife so that'll tell you
a little something plato was as far as
we know a bachelor
aristotle i frankly don't even know but
they were they would not they would not
be what you call family men nietzsche
has a wonderful expression which i will
cite
in fear and trepidation since the
interview is almost over nietzsche says
a married philosopher is a contradiction
in terms
and i won't give a detailed commentary
on that statement where where when did
nietzsche live uh second half of the
19th century 1845 to 1900 and where was
he from uh nietzsche was a german a
german friedrich nietzsche
in boston
professor stanley rosen has been our
helper here among other things to try to
figure out all this thank you very much
sir for coming in and
and uh explaining to us philosophy and
plato and aristotle and all the rest
thank you so much for asking me i hope
it wasn't too tedious
stanley rosen has written about 14 books
on plato nietzsche and other
philosophers if you'd like to know more
about his works contact the author by
email srosen at bu.edu
you can use this program in your
classroom and we've designed some tools
to help go to our website booktv.org